I'm not surprised because whenever we
have an economic downturn it suddenly
becomes apparent how manifestly our
employment based system fails America I
mean people are losing their jobs and at
the same time they're losing their
health insurance precisely when they
most need security they feel most
insecure so we have seen a big increase
in the share of Americans who lack
health insurance and the only reason
that that increase has been muted in the
most recent economic downturn is because
government has stepped in in the form of
Medicaid and the Children's Health
Insurance Program to soften the blow we
know that about a third of Americans are
saying right now that they're worried
about losing their health insurance
coverage so when the economy goes sour
and it's gone very very sour recently
that really accentuates people's
concerns about their security and about
health care at the same time if you
think about it this has been the leading
cause of Democrats since the Great
Depression since Franklin Roosevelt
thought about including health insurance
in the Social Security Act back in 1935
it's the great unfinished business of
the New Deal if you will and you know
Truman wasn't able to do it Johnson
decided he'd just covered the Aged you
know Clinton most recently tried and
failed to enact a program that would
expand health insurance coverage to all
or most Americans and so for Democrats
this is the moment if you think about it
they've got large majorities in Congress
they have a progressive president who's
committed to this cause and it really
isn't just a political cause if you
think about it it is central to our
economy of performing well if you know
President Obama during the campaign kept
talking about change and hope and a new
foundation being laid for our economy
and health care is really a crucial
place to begin it drains our government
of money the federal government is going
to go deeper and deeper into the red if
we don't control health care costs it
burdens our businesses it is you know
hurting working families it means that
millions of Americans feel insecure it
means our health care is much more
costly than it should be and it means
you know quite frankly that our health
care system performs much less well than
it should our basic health statistics
and even the statistics that is that are
that are used to measure the quality of
care at the high level suggests that
we're really
price for not having a system that's
inclusive and it's efficient and we we
need to address that so i think that's
that's why i'm not surprised i think
that the reason that it's moved so
quickly is precisely that it has to you
know if the President had not moved
quickly to enact health care reform in
this year I think he really would have
been waiting until you know his second
term if he had one because it is the
case that as the election approaches
it's going to be much harder to take on
such a big issue and after a midterm
election in which you know this the
historical record suggests the Democrats
are going to lose some seeds and the way
the economy is right now they might lose
a fair number of seeds you know after an
election like that no one's going to
have the sort of urge to really take on
such a big issue so this is the time and
this is the moment as President Obama
and often says and I think it's
remarkable but necessary that they've
moved so quickly